I always tried to put a little bit of my
soul in the guitar this is a mixer of
sweetness which I sometimes have not
always a little bit of bravery
[Music]
[Music]
the part that I love the most about
working with wood it's touching it the
feeling of the wood in my hands it's
something that always reminds me about
Who I am where are my roots where I
belong to the wood needs to be dried at
least for thirty years which means that
I'm using the materials are my
grandfather boat I never met him he died
one month before I was born so I get to
touch the things that he picked without
knowing there will be for me because I'm
the first woman in the family to make
guitars so it's it's quite special once
you have picked the materials then you
start to prepare all the parts of the
guitar we always start with shaping of
the neck second part it's the top when
we decide the materials which is not
which one of the templates that we have
a we're gonna use
[Music]
the first thing that you do when you cut
it is to put it in the cellar
this will every samal that we use for
the for the top on the back to give the
guitar this little cube so it sounds
better and then for the top we need to
put the rosette in it
and it's little pieces of food and we
make the draw in the design and we have
to start putting every single piece so
it matches the row said it's one of the
most difficult parts to do but it's also
one of the most creative ones where you
are allowed to do whatever you want it
takes me like two months and a half to
make a couple of guitars because we are
always making a couple of them so when
one is gluing we can work with the other
one actually when a guitarist gluing it
when I use this old form of clamps these
ones we made ourselves here so we can
put pressure on the guitar the
Flemington classical guitar they may
look II hope that in the construction
they're different classical player they
always look for a neat note bright sound
but the Fleming ones they just want sold
[Music]
everybody asks about that I'd spending
you have to put them under the water for
a couple of hours and then you do this
bending with heat we use a little oven
and if you get the reed wet through the
process you can bend the sides to the
separate a guitar neck on the business
started with the uncle of my grandfather
in 1915 nowadays in this works of we are
three people plus my father's at first
continuing the tradition it was not
something that I had in mind and my
father suggested me to come to the
workshop in the evenings just to try and
I found a beautiful do you know how the
family business world
and how to make any time the first it's
hard that I close I remember going back
home and my smile couldn't be bigger
because it's the first moment that you
see a complete guitar for joining of the
back we need to put enough pressure to
stick the back on the sides but it's not
so much so there sites could break the
tradition is to give your first guitar
to your mother but I'm not a boy so I
decided to give it to my father which
was my master
I was totally afraid that it would be a
mistake and a mess and it wouldn't sound
but it did sound and it did sound well
and I couldn't be more proud I remember
this as one of the most exciting days
man once you have stacked all the guitar
together then you start with a
fingerboard
we always use a boney from Africa and
it's a really tough material because it
has a lot of density it's very heavy
you have to be very careful in the
distribution of the frets if you are
mistaking by just one millimeter you
wouldn't be able to tune it it would be
impossible after that you only have two
to give the last patches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once a guitar is finished you have to
adjust the neck bone and the bridge bone
and this is really important because
that will decide the tension of the
strings sometimes you need a whole day
to adjust the guitar to find it perfect
but I guess it will never be perfect
because it depends on the person play
the guitar to have really good memories
with flamenco music and for me it's it's
it means home actually it comes from the
heart
[Music]
I have this romantic idea in that this
is my brain that I live in this world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you